Once your project is ready, you can output media to disk and share images and videos with your audience.
Open the file named 3-Media that's been provided to you.
Start by setting the time of day to around 4.30pm. We'll change that again later if we need to.
Also unhide the animated people and the grass using the Scene Graph.
Go to the Media panel in the dock. Here, you can define still images, videos, and panoramas to export.
There are also two other options that we'll discuss in a moment.
To define a still image, the process is easy. Adjust the view to a shot you like, make sure Image Mode is active, and click the plus sign.
This creates a snapshot that you can now edit independently from the editor.
You can rename the view, but more importantly, you can adjust it in terms of time of day, exposure, weather, all of which would be parameters affecting this image and this image alone.
A simple example would be to have a shot in daytime and duplicate the image to get a shot at nighttime.
You can now switch back and forth between the two.
Another example may be to view the scene in a different season, by duplicating an image and changing the appropriate parameters.
If you change your point of view, you will need to use the Refresh icon to update the image.
For some shots, you may decide to use a depth of field camera effect.
Other interesting applications may lead you to use special filters for certain images.
At any time, you can quit Media Mode to go back to regular editing.
Another type of media that you can use is a 360-degree panorama.
Much like with still images, you position your camera where you need it to be, I'll use the Caffe, and then go to the Media Panorama panel and use the plus sign.
You get the same options you usually get with images, including camera effects and filters.
The 360 panorama will be created once you save it to disk, which we'll do in a moment.
Next up are videos. Go to that panel.
First, position your camera where the video will start. We'll animate the view to go around the building.
The current camera position will be recorded as the first frame when you click the plus sign.
Note that the video length is set by default to 10 seconds. We'll expand that to 30 to give ourselves enough time around the building.
To animate the camera, move your view to another point, and then click the plus sign on the right side of the clip to create a new keyframe.
Keep on moving. Move and adjust the camera position and create additional keyframes as needed.
At the end, duplicate the last keyframe to just let the camera settle in its position.
Ultimately, each sub-clip can be set to its own time of day to animate that effect if you so choose.
Scrub the animation to see the results.
Go back to the main video menu and rename the clip and then exit media mode.
Now that you have defined your media, it is time to output it to disk. This is done by using the Export panel on the dock.
Here you can choose which media to export. For example, under Images, you'll find the still images you have defined.
You can choose the ones you want to render. You can do the same with Panoramas and with videos.
There are some restrictions when using the community version of Twinmotion.
Images and videos are saved to HD format and will have a watermark on them.
Panoramas can be rendered as high as 6K in resolution. That's a small sacrifice to pay for free software.
When you are ready to proceed, click the Start Export button.
Choose or create an output folder and let the system process the data.
This may take a while, especially when processing videos, so you may want to take a little break.
Once the process is over, then you can view your files or share them with friends and clients.
Another way of sharing media is through Presenter. In the Media panel, choose Presentation.
Here you can create a presentation that includes some or all of the media you've already defined.
You can simply drag media and organize it on a timeline and you can mix between types.
I think I'll use images and videos only for this and leave the panorama out.
Once you have defined your presentation, you can go again to the Export panel.
You can blank out the previous outputs since they're already saved and include the presentation file you have just defined.
If you export it, again be aware that it might take a while to render, but also...
it will create a self-executable that allows others to interact with your project without having Twinmotion installed.
Because of that fact, Presenter saves more than just media.
It compiles everything it needs to run the self-executable and therefore, presentation files tend to be large on the hard drives.
The end result would look like this.
And know that you can totally walk around and interact with your scene.
Just select any image that you like and start walking around.
This leaves one additional media option to learn about, working with phases, coming up in the next and last video.